we've talked about Poland recently on
visual politic I'll leave a video link
in the description below to recap its
growth and development process in the
last decades have been vertiginous since
1992 the Polish economy has grown as an
average rate of over 4% per year
commencer other European nations Poland
has been one of the most prosperous
countries sitting just behind Ireland
Estonia and Latvia in fact even though
it may seem surprising given their
historical circumstances polls are
already within the European average in
terms of poverty risk
in other words Poland has been one of
the countries that has best managed to
digest the political economic and social
transitions that the former Soviet bloc
countries had to face after the USSR
collapsed but not everything that
glitters is gold
they have great statistics and economic
data that's no doubt about that in that
regard there undeniably successful
what's happening in the political and
social arena well that's exactly where
things get a bit murkier especially if
you care about such things as civil
liberties by now you probably realize
it's easier to change an economy than a
society societal change
it just takes much longer
as we'll see Poland along with Hungary
is probably the most conservative and
traditionalist country in the entire
European Union this might give you a bit
of an idea christianity is part of our
national identity the Catholic Church
was and is the preacher and holder of
the only commonly held system of values
in Poland outside of it we have only
nihilism
Yatta Slav Kaczynski former prime
minister and the current leader of the
Law and Justice Party the largest
political party in the Polish Parliament
and it's not just a matter of religion
this country has also been characterized
by promoting a political agenda that for
many directly clashes with the EU's
principles do you want to know more
about what is happening in Poland's how
truly conservative its society is what's
the agenda that has become a real
headache for the European authorities
well listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
basically if you're not Catholic white
and straight in Poland
you might get into trouble it's safe to
say that in one way or another you'll
feel outcast by a large part of society
and also by the government poland's
ruling party fuels anti-lgbt sentiment
ahead of elections polish election
leader of poland's law and justice party
targets gay rights as threat to society
in this country rejection of everything
beyond the traditional Christian family
model is very present within Polish
society for example in most European
countries the government's main party
calling LGBT people a threat to society
would be unthinkable however here it
happens every day
Poland's is just kind of like
[Music]
now how can a country like this which
somehow promotes the harassment of
minorities fit into a project like the
European Union and well that's the big
dilemma
because polish policy is sometimes
rather hard to understand on the one
hand polls continue to reelect a
nationalist anti-immigration and
homophobic party to leave the country
that is they choose leadership that is
against everything the European
Community project represents yes on the
other hand Polish society has the most
favorable impression of the European
Union check this out
[Music]
of course it's one thing to like the
European Union and a very different one
to be willing to comply with the
guidelines that emanate from Brussels
so check out how the polls are going
with that you top court Poland broke EU
law with judicial reform Poland Hungary
broke EU laws by refusing to host
migrants court adviser Poland defies
Brussels by vowing to stick to coal
poland plans to prioritize curbing its
reliance on Russian energy and so
continuing its dependence on coal over
signing up to the e u--'s net zero
emissions target and a move that is set
to put Warsaw on a collision course with
Brussels over climate policy the
European Union strives to make fair
rules for its member states and when it
comes to the crunch Poland goes rogue
but if they don't agree with you
recommendations how can it be that poles
have such a favorable opinion of the
European Union well we're going to
answer that question but we're gonna
take it step-by-step because believe me
it when I say that Polish politics is
well rather crazy
[Music]
it has been more than two years since
Brussels called Poland's out over its
alleged undemocratic drift so could
Poland's be turning towards
authoritarianism why is the first big
question so let's take a look oh god
knows Oh Democrats yet
Oh what is never said polish democracy
in check
[Music]
it turns out this one thing that's much
more important than Poland's loyalty to
the European Union I'm talking about the
health of democracy the truth is that
today polish democracy isn't in a good
place and that's rather worry what has
been most aligning has been the Polish
government's increasingly personalist
shift for example there's been the
attempt of Yaroslav Kachinsky the pis
party leader to reduce the retirement
age of the Supreme Court judges from 70
to 65 which would mean kicking up 40% of
them out naturally they would need to be
replaced by other judges one likely to
be on good terms with the party
this situation became so serious that
the change was halted by the European
Court of Justice as they considered it
to be a clear attempt for political
control over the judiciary however
despite all of this the government has
continued to move in that same direction
in many ways for example in 2017 the
government got Parliament to approve
three very controversial laws this was
Kachinsky 's personal push to control
the country literally nothing and no one
was going to stand in his way
[Music]
basically the three laws not only
intended to grant legislators enormous
power over the judiciary's general
council but also gave the Justice
Minister himself who by the way is also
the Attorney General the right to
appoint local court judges and chiefs
you can imagine what this would mean in
terms of political control over the
courts
[Applause]
[Music]
in an unexpected turn of events the
country's president Andrzej Duda who's
sympathetic towards the P is that
doesn't actually belong to the party
soon vetoed two of those three laws only
allowing the Minister of Justice to
appoints the local court chiefs
[Music]
but that wasn't the end of the story the
government's obsessions you control
justice is constant
Poland is purging its prosecutor's
disciplinary chamber for Polish judges
not independent says EC J's top advisor
so by this point many of you are
probably wondering what's the EU doing
about all of this well we can almost say
that the European community authorities
have launched a frontal attack on Poland
over all of these issues in fact for the
first time in history Brussels activated
the disciplinary action mechanism
against a member country something that
could end with suspending Poland's right
to vote in European decisions Poland
taken to --use top court over alleged
political control of judiciary and what
can I say they have every reason to do
so seeing politicians messing with the
justice system is very worrying however
the confrontations don't end with the
Polish government's attempt to assault
its own courts and end the separation of
powers
[Music]
if we also add in all of the current
ruling parties and a phobic ultra
Catholic and homophobic policies and we
find a country that directly contests
all of the actions that the European
Union has taken in recent years
Poland bashes immigrants but quietly
takes Christian ones liberals fear
unrest as Polish Catholic Church doubles
down on anti-gay rhetoric the Archbishop
of Krakow Marek jedrus eggski described
Poland as under siege from a quote
rainbow plague of gay rights campaigners
he compared to Poland's former communist
rulers in poland's upcoming election the
law and Justice Party is demonizing the
LGBT community to win basically the
political directions of the European
Union and Poland's are apples and
oranges and at this point you might be
thinking well Simon why then two poles
have such a good image of the European
Union while the truth is that the pis
the government since therefore the
Polish society don't dislike everything
that the European Union has to offer
in fact there's something they seem to
be quite fond of
[Music]
money everyone loves it
criticizing the EU in Europe isn't
unusual that happens all over but here
is where polls take the cake complying
with community regulations regarding
political and judicial guarantees
respecting minorities or accepting these
6,200 applicants that Brussels assigned
to Poland in the distribution of
refugees within the community well
that's not happening
but money oh well money that's a whole
other thing they use money is of course
well received it's welcomed with open
arms and a huge smile and we're not
talking about small change here since
Poland joined the EU it has received
more than a hundred and ten billion
dollars in community aid the European
cohesion fund alone has awarded Poland
more than eighty five billion dollars
for the 2014 to 2020 period to finance
infrastructure projects such as highways
and railways
in fact Poland receives more funds from
the cohesion funds than any other new
country as a side note contrary to what
is usually claimed this type of aid
wasn't key in Poland's economic takeoff
not at all but it did help and this
promotes a question that has more and
more political EU leaders scratching
their heads should the EU community make
it a condition to provide financial aid
only to the countries that agree to
comply with the union's rules and
resolutions should Brussels frees funds
allocated to member states that have
anti-liberal plist governments that
don't fulfill their responsibilities
well it looks like it's going that way
brussels tells poland EU is quote not a
cow you can milk and in a way it makes
sense doesn't it the fact is that right
now the EU cohesion funds terms and
distribution for the 2021 to 2027 period
are being negotiated and it looks like
Poland won't do well Poland to get 23%
less EU 2020 to 20 27 plug it and if
this news is confirmed Poland could lose
almost a quarter of the money it
currently receives from the EU although
with just over 64 billion dollars it
would continue to be the largest fund
recipients but even this budget
reduction is not what it seems
[Music]
this cancer actually has nothing to do
with the punishment or anything like
that but with the fact that Poland's as
we told you at the beginning of the
video is a wealthier country today with
better infrastructure and it's closer to
the development average of the rest of
the European Union that's and the fact
that brexit has forced Brussels to
tighten its bells as it can no longer
count on the United Kingdom's annual
contribution to the community coffers
and while this is where we are
in any case this raises a question given
polish society's political tendencies
and its enormous divergence from the
path brussels has set wouldn't
decreasing Poland's funds slowly push
this country further away from the Union
won't the Polish nationalist parties
just exploit these cuts as proof of
community interference and the most
important question of all polish and
Hungarian policies Eastern European
policies even compatible with the
European Union but leave your answer in
the comment section below and I really
hope you did enjoy this video please do
hit like if you did and don't forget to
subscribe for brand new videos also
please do check and our friends at the
reconsider mediate podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine
also this channel is possible because of
patreon hands our patrons on that
platform please consider joining them
and supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage and as
always I'll see you in the next video